Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today at the end of the week for episode 81!
Our 81st episode!
81!
BAU BAU!
Wow, for all of you who are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
That's a Friday, Wednesday, Monday!
And it's hosted by us...
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
So please, tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, I have a feeling that today is a very beautiful way to end off the week.
Right.
And we're going to a wonderful weekend.
Yay!
Let's all have a wonderful day, Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
There is something that wasn't so beautiful.
Ruffians.
Now what is... Yeah, another... Pero Sighting.
Let's see where he is this time!
I can't get away from him.
Okay.
Down.
A cake!
For us!
Cute!
But, oh, what a surprise.
Pero emerged from the fog.
I'll hang up this cake and eat the decorations.
Well, that's not very nice of him.
But, well, actually, I kind of feel like it looks like he perfectly fits there, no?
Ah, well, I guess, unfortunately for him, you know, he fits there.
Huh?
Ruffians!
Where do you want to start eating the cake from?
Yeah.
Right.
From his face?
From the peron!
Eat the peron!
From the right of his eye!
The ears!
The tummy!
Yeah, I think the tummy sticks a knife right in there!
Well, unfortunately, I guess for Pero, he kind of made the worst decision on where to pop out from, huh?
You picked the wrong cake to start, Pero!
Yeah.
Especially an ice cream cake!
One that was made especially for us two.
Why would you go into an ice cream cake?
That's cold, huh?
I guess it's delicious, but...
Thank you so much for the cake!
It looks both delicious and lovely!
Hope you enjoy cutting Pero into pieces and eating him!
Eating him... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
You know, I just, I feel so happy because I feel like every FUWAMOCO Morning we could do it.
Right, we have something super happy to share with you.
Well, this time Ruffians, we hit another huge milestone!
We now have over 700! 500!
750,000 Ruffians here on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
So many Ruffians, it's hard for me to say it properly.
I keep on saying 150,000, it's hard.
It's too big of a number now, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your love and support during these past six months.
I don't know.
How are we already at this milestone?
I'm so surprised.
You know what?
It's a huge one, right?
You know when we debuted, we had that one goal, right?
Do you remember?
Do you remember, Ruffian?
1 million subscribers within 1 year.
Yeah, 1 year from debut.
Maybe it surprised you a bit.
But you know Ruffians, we're hungry puppies.
And you know now we're 6 months, almost 7 months since debut.
We're continuing to do our best, you know, reach that big goal.
But like we've always said, you know, more than anything, it's the journey that's important, right?
It really, really is.
We think that so far, it's been a very beautiful journey.
And that's what matters most, right?
Yeah, we really hope, Ruffians, that you'll continue to have lots of fun with us.
And that maybe even more Ruffians will decide to join us along the way, too.
Yeah!
Let's all BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Onto 1 million Ruffians!
1 million BAU BAUs!
Oh no, is that what we're gonna have to do, Moco-chan?
Oh no.
I just did it to ourselves.
1 million Ruffians.
1 million BAU BAUs.
Can we even do that?
I don't know.
We could try.
Committed to it!
1 million BAUs too!
Gotta celebrate big things with a big BAU, right?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
That would be so stupid.
Right!
Right.
Yeah, we better get BAU BAUing.
How are you gonna count them?
That's the funny part, Ruffians.
You're gonna count them!
Quiet it!
Right.
Oh no!
BAU BAU!
It's a group effort, okay?
Right!
You know, just like this journey's been, it's a group effort, so... Thank you Ruffians for making it such a special journey!
BAU BAU!
Fuwamoco!
Well, you know, as a part of our last
Our last Valentine's Day!
As a part of our Valentine's Day, our last present to you!
Our last present to you on Valentine's Day.
We released a brand new song cover of Let Me Be With You from the anime show, BAU BAU!
We're so so happy to share this one with you because it's a really precious song to us.
We really had such a fun time recording it, you know, with all the harmonies.
I'm so happy to be able to share it with so many Ruffians who might be discovering it for the first time too.
It's so cute!
Thank you!
Nostalgia!
So, if you haven't had a listen to it yet, please go check it out, okay?
I don't know.
I think it's the perfect song for the upcoming spring season!
It's a bit of an earworm too, okay?
You might find yourself going... Throughout your day, okay?
Be warned!
I know that when I was brushing my teeth, I was like... I'm glad you like it so much, Ruffians!
Please listen to it more!
Maybe it can be your soundtrack for spring.
We'll be happy.
BAU BAU!
Also, FUWAMOCO, we received a very special Valentine's gift from none other than our beloved mama, Icomochi-mama!
Look!
We're so cute!
Thank you, Icomochi-mama, for always being so warm and loving and doting on us too!
It actually makes us really happy!
You know, to see Icomochi-mama's tweets of her thoughts while watching our streams too!
You know?
And like, often we'll go to the toilet and say, you know, BAU BAU now, right before our stream.
And we'll see, you know, that Icomochi-mama just woke up because of the ohayou tweet, you know?
So, I always kind of think, ah, baby!
You know?
Did she?
Wake up just to watch us stream!
I can't help but kind of think that, you know?
And Icomochi-mama was really excited about our Valentine's Day stream and the cover of Let Me Be With You too.
So we're always so thankful!
No, I. Actually, Icomochi-mama said that we don't need to tweet back and say thank you to her so much.
But we want to!
We want to!
Because she's our dear mama, okay?
And she means so much to us.
So, so much.
So, we'll continue!
Watch and learn!
We love you Icomochi-mama!
BAU BAU!
We're so lucky Ruffians.
Such lucky puppies.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Icomochi-mama.
Thank you.
Ruffians.
I had a very strange and in-depth dream last night.
It felt very immersive.
I don't really know what went on, but do you want to hear?
Well, here I go!
You need to pay attention because it's strange, okay?
I'm going to do my best to explain it.
So, to begin, we're at some kind of party-like event with all the Ruffians.
And there's a big sprint line that we had to run.
Like a marathon?
Like a race?
Yeah, but a sprint.
A long but small one.
So I ran it.
And I don't know if I had a good time score or not.
It doesn't really seem like it was that important.
I don't even know, I just ran it.
But I finished it.
And then, all the Ruffians, they took that, what was the sprint line?
And they rolled it up into a big crepe.
Like the size of a yoga mat-sized crepe.
A very, very big crepe, okay.
It was a surprise, okay?
So both of us walked into another room and all the Ruffians had the crepe all decorated on a huge plate with some strawberries and cheesecake slices and, you know, other berries for decoration.
And it looked really, really nice.
Beautiful.
Good job, Ruffians.
So I was happy because obviously- A creep, Ruffians!
Not grapes!
A creep!
A creep, okay?
But you know, I was happy because it was obvious that you all did your best together to make it look nice.
But...
Truth be told, as soon as I looked at it, I turned to Fuwawa and said, Fuwawa, if we try to eat this, we're gonna get sick.
Why should we do it?
You can't eat a crepe as big as a yoga mat, Ruffians.
And then, there was one Ruffian who tried to show me some sort of parody comic that had a bunch of different characters in it.
It was very thick, like, and there's characters- Like how many pages?
Like, a lot.
A couple, like, hundred or so.
That's a lot!
It was big, it was thick.
I think you had 20 pages.
No, no, no.
It was thick.
But there's a bunch of different characters like there's Batman and Hello Kitty and FUWAMOCO in it!
We're up there with Batman and Hello Kitty though!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
So I looked at it thinking that it was just something they wanted to show me but I was disappointed because FUWAMOCO in it didn't really seem like FUWAMOCO's personality was.
We were saying things that we wouldn't usually say, and you know, it just wasn't our personalities.
It just seemed like a drawing of some character!
Very derivative, yeah.
So, maybe I was a bit harsh!
I said that, that part of the comic was a bit of a shame and it took me out of the world.
And I sort of went on a little tangent.
And then, I noticed that they looked really disappointed.
And then I realized, maybe they had made this comic...
So, I was really worried!
And trying to find him to apologize!
And then I woke up!
I thought it wasn't theirs.
I thought it was, like, you know, maybe a company have released it.
Because it was really big!
It was all just a misunderstanding.
It was a misunderstanding!
What?
It was a strange but happy dream.
You never did find the Ruffian though.
So Ruffians, that was you!
Moco-chan, sorry!
But I was happy because the Ruffian went.
That comic was terrible.
It wasn't terrible!
It was well done, it's just, you know, sometimes things are like that.
FUWAMOCO doesn't say BAU BAU, it says FUWAMOCO.
Right?
You know, if you get a doujinshi and then it's like, it's cute, but the personality isn't there.
Is it really?
You know... Right?
That's to think about!
BAU BAU!
HSDJMoco-chan.
Thank you.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
We talked about it a little bit yesterday, but we have a confession to make.
FUWAMOCO, you know we're very fluffy and fuzzy.
We don't get that grumpy.
No!
That's not a part of FUWAMOCO.
But, well, we talked about it, but sometimes we have a tendency to watch videos of fancy cafes and, you know, food places on YouTube!
You know the little videos with the song... Or the...
Actually, I can get pretty heated while watching them.
I think this...
Without a doubt, it's the most toxic thing about us.
Because you know, Ruffians will be like lots of restaurants that try to make cute and fancy items for people to take photos of, right?
You know, for the grounds and everything, that sort of thing.
Yeah, but, well...
You know, like, they'll have, like, a sad crepe and they'll feel it overflowing with this oily whipped cream and the whole way up and then, oh, I'll just kind of brulee it so it'll make you nice.
It looks visually pleasing and then I'll just be selling it for $20!
Yeah, yeah!
How are you gonna eat that without being sick?
It's just, it's just a ton of cheap oily whipped cream.
How are, why do you want to just eat whipped cream?
Yeah.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm FUWAMOCO!
Of course, it makes us so happy!
And they say it's a sandwich, but they give you a spoon?
I'm sorry!
When was the last time you ate a sandwich with a spoon?
We get a bit toxic.
You know, Ruffians will even see our videos and bring it to each other and be like, How dare they!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
So, Ruffians, you know when ordering fancy foods and going around to cute cafes,
Probably best to avoid those silly items, you know, like that.
Otherwise, you might get a bit grumpy.
Don't be like fancy cafes, but it's important to go to the nice ones, and not the silly ones.
Pick the nice things, you know.
Treat yourself to something worth it, okay?
Not just a crate filled with whipping cream.
It's just whipping cream!
Yeah, or they'll put like the...
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
That's all.
That's FUWAMOCO's toxic tweet.
I like the nice ones.
Not the not good ones.
BAU BAU!
Are you hungry for sweets?
You have the whole rest of your day to find a good sweet to treat yourself with.
Well, maybe this next part is not gonna help, huh?
We've been hearing some big reports about this new mysterious and viral trend.
It goes by the name of Marshmallow Mania.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's hard to tell what exactly it is, but it seems like a lot of the talk generated around it is actually, uh, the less-than-stellar reviews.
No, it seems like the reviews about it are sort of mixed.
You know, half of them being fluffy and the other half being fuzzy.
Oh no.
Fluffy and fuzzy marshmallows.
The other big question surrounding it is what is it?
Is it a popular drink?
I knew it.
Well, you know, it could be like a milk latte with marshmallow fuzz and even more marshmallow sprinkled on top.
Maybe it's a special dessert.
Marshmallows covered in melted marshmallow topped with koi sugar and then bruleed.
It definitely sounds like, you know, something you need to take photos of.
Then upload to social media.
Marshmallow mania for the ground.
Just watch out though, cause you know, FUWAMOCO might find your video and then decide to hate on it.
Ruffians, maybe let us know if you find out more about marshmallow mania.
The Doggy Pack has heard more about it.
So if you're curious, try asking them.
Maybe?
BAU BAU!
No FUWAMOCO!
Weird trends high.
Trends are weird high.
Trends are weird.
Yeah.
Although I heard that probably don't ask Biboo what Marshmallow Mania is about.
I don't think that's her area of trending.
No, she's more on the other trends.
The other trends.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Let's take out- take out?
Take out?
Are we gonna bodyslam it?
Let's take out the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Daisy!
Look at those beautiful chompers!
I just love you!
Doggy Dentist!
You know, she's apparently gotten a bit older now and finally just realized how fun toys are.
And that tug of war, it rocks!
It really actually does, I agree with Daisy.
Tug of war.
After playing a bunch of pantlings, she also turns into a cuddle bug.
Cute.
Well, how does Daisy BAU BAU go?
I like that!
I think it's beautiful jumpers.
Daisy is a sweetheart who loves life together with you!
You know, she just figured out how fun it is to play together.
So I think she'd really like to be able to catch up on all those tug-of-war matches when she missed them all.
Now is the time!
Please let her cuddle with you and give her lots of head pats afterwards too, okay?
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Today I Went on a Walk.
We have De-den!
That looks like it was a chilly walk.
A bit cold, huh?
Hopefully the snow has all melted now.
Goodbye snow.
Yeah, well, we're glad that you're getting out and about between our streams.
Yeah!
We'll do our best to do the same too, huh?
Right.
It always feels so good to stretch the paws and get moving.
Yeah, it's really important to do so, Ruffians.
So, you know what that sounds like?
It might be perfect to go on a walk after FUWAMOCO Morning!
Give it a shot, okay?
BAU BAU!
Don't forget to use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING when you do, okay?
And next for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
FUWAMOCO!
I love your Let Me Be With You cover so much!
I was just wondering, if you're thinking of putting English lyric captions on the song covers, I think it would enhance the listening experience for the Ruffians.
Thank you!
Thank you for the question!
We really love you!
We love you so so much!
But you know, well...
It's a little tricky.
We really, really, you know, lyrics are important to us.
They're very important.
It's not that easy because, you know, we need to ask the creators if it's okay.
Because, you know, it's their baby, too.
And then, you know, we need to get them to check the translation of the lyrics.
They agree if it's accurate.
And then, you know,
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Many Ruffians from all over the world can understand, too.
It's too bad about covers, huh?
You'll just have to look up a translation yourself.
If that's okay to ask.
BAU BAU!
It would be nice, huh?
It can't be, huh?
With originals it's different, you know?
But covers, it's a little tricky.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for all your submissions.
You're a very, very important part of FUWAMOCO Morning, so we hope you'll continue to send us little parts of your world.
Your doggies, your walks, your questions, your Pero Sightings.
All of them, okay?
We're always waiting!
We're waiting!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And for our next team coming up today, we have
Lethal Company!
Together with all of Advent.
Yeah, Moco-chan, you've been really itching to play.
So, we're looking forward to it.
Actually, I'm not playing.
Fuwawa wanted to play recently.
She thought she would be good.
So she played on her own.
Solo little company.
She couldn't find the entrance.
No!
And then I got found.
Before I found the entrance!
So, well, I'm not the greatest asset to the company, but maybe Moco-chan, maybe you can be the greatest asset to the company.
I wanna be good.
Let's give up on me.
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule, well, this weekend,
We have a bit of a homework day on Sunday, but that's okay because on Saturday, we're gonna be- Metal Gear Solid 2!
We're finishing off Metal Gear Solid 2.
Can we stop Solidus in the end?
I really don't know at this point.
We're at the end.
We'll have to see what happens.
Please remember how to do things properly, Moco-chan.
I'll do my best!
And the final battle awaits.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us this week and for tuning into FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Asti!
BAU BAU!
Pup-chan.
G-Galaxy.
BAU BAU!
McVerdin.
Dark Master.
BAU BAU!
Winter Madness.
Dandoro.
BAU BAU!
Darius.
Exama.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!